the bushes bitter backlash that's a
subject of tonight's bonus angle until
Donald Trump came along the Republican
Party hadn't won a national election
since 2004 when George W Bush narrowly
defeated John Kerry after that was
pretty much all downhill
the GOP went on to lose the house the
Senate and the presidency twice the
nation had become disillusioned by the
enormous physical and financial toll of
our interventions in both Iraq and
Afghanistan grassroots voters rose up
against george w bush's immigration
amnesty and his nomination of his pal
harriet miers to the supreme court but
now the bushes are lashing out at Donald
Trump you saw the recent not-so-veiled
hit on the sitting president by george w
bush and by the way neither bush we find
out voted for Donald Trump while that's
a shock and George HW in a new book
called Trump a blowhard a thousand
points of insult George W joined in on
the sniping he said this guy doesn't
know what it means to be president and
his father also said of Trump I don't
like him I don't know much about him not
thrilled about him being the leader
well this coming from a guy god bless
him great Patriot though he didn't
exactly thrill the voters himself in
1992 to Bush 41 and Bush 43 where were
you when we needed you during Obama's
two terms we needed you then to speak
out against outrages that were being
perpetrated on the American public
against Obamacare after Benghazi how
about when the IRS was targeting
conservatives where were you when we
needed you silent crickets totally
silent or did we have to read your lips
George W is worried that Trump's tenure
may mean that we've seen the last
Republican president funny huh that's
what all of us thought in 2008 when W
was doing the big bailouts had 26
percent approval rating and had us
bogged down into
Wars until the Tea Party came around in
2009
conservatives fretted that the country
was lost for a generation the Bush
family apparently can't come to terms of
the fact that the voters rejected their
globalist worldview and have basically
moved on in recent years the Bush family
has become pretty tight with the
Clintons and the Obamas they found more
common ground with them than they have
with the grass Rizzo ters in their own
party and if Bush era policies let's
face it of open borders and open markets
and endless wars was so popular the
former two-term governor of Florida he
was popular when his governor - Jeb Bush
well he would have handily beaten that
political neophyte Donald Trump in his
home state primary but well we know how
that ended don't we low-energy indeed
I'm gonna show dynasty it worked in the
1980s because he at Joan Collins and
John Forsythe and their leading roles
but the country had had it with the bush
dynasty and what their policies had
wrought on America wasn't personal it
was the policies so the voters canceled
that political show no amount of
grousing by the bitter bushes is gonna
change that the voters are simply not
that into them anymore what I said in my
CPAC speech in February of 2016 and I
wrote about in my new book billionaire
at the barricades turned out to be
depressingly accurate Jeb and Hillary
should just dispense with all the
formalities and just run on the same
ticket in 2016
think of the bumper sticker would have
been pretty catchy coach 2016 what
difference does it make